no candidate received more than half
of all the first preference votes cast
in the election
the two candidates who received the
highest number of preference votes
remain in the contest they are sadiq
aman khan
and sean bailey i will now announce the
number of second preference votes
cast for each of these two candidates
sadiq aman khan received 192
313 second preference votes
added to his total first preference
votes
this gives sadiq aman khan a total of
one million
two hundred and six thousand and thirty
four
votes sean bailey
received eighty four thousand five
hundred and fifty
second preference votes added to his
total first preference votes
this gives sean bailey a total of nine
nine hundred and seventy seven thousand
six hundred and one
votes i therefore declare
sadiq aman khan elected as the mayor of
london
i will now ask sadiq aman khan the mayor
of london
to come to the stage to give a short
speech
and i will afterwards ask sean bailey to
speak
i want to say thank you from the bottom
of my heart i'm deeply humbled
by the trust londoners have placed in me
to continue leading the greatest
city on earth i promise to
strain every sinew to help build
a better and brighter future for london
after the dark days of the pandemic
and to create a greener
fairer and safer city where all
londoners
get the opportunities they need to
fulfill
their potential i'm proud
to have won an overwhelming mandate
today i want to thank everyone
who voted for me labour voters
and non-labor voters
and also i want to speak directly
to every londoner who didn't vote for me
this week i'll never ignore
your voice your concerns
or your worries i'll always be a mayor
for
all londoners working to improve the
lives
of every single person in this city
the results of the elections around the
uk
show that our country and even our city
remain deeply divided
the scars of brexit are yet to heal
a crude culture war is pushing us
further apart
there's a growing gap between our cities
and
towns and economic inequality
is getting worth worse both within
london
and between different parts of our
country
so as we now seek to confront the
enormity
of the challenge ahead and as we
endeavor
to rebuild from this pandemic we simply
must use this moment of national
recovery
to heal those damaging divisions
i often talk about the different
experiences
i've lived during my life and how
they've shaped
my identity i do so
because these experiences have forged my
cast iron belief
that there's far more that unites us
than divides us i grew up
on a council estate a working-class boy
a child of immigrants but i'm now
the mayor of london i'm a londoner
through and through this city is in my
blood
but i'm also a patriotic englishman
and a brit who's proud to represent
this nation's great capital
the experiences i've had through my life
have shaped
my belief that we all have a
responsibility
to do everything we can to build the
bridges
that bring us together rather than the
walls
that can only drive us further apart
this virus doesn't care whether you live
in london
or liverpool whether you're a brexiteer
or a remainer
or what what you think it means to be
woke
we're only defeating it by acting
together and by helping
each other so now we must capture and
harness
that spirit of unity and cooperation
to build a better and brighter
future and it's in this spirit i promise
to lead london over the next three years
building bridges between the different
communities
in our city building bridges across
cultural
social and class divides building
bridges between london and the rest
of the country to ensure london can play
its part
in a national recovery and
building bridges between city hall and
the government
because we must all work together
to build a brighter greener
and more equal future for london and
for our entire country after the
pandemic
it's not a competition between areas
people without a good job or living in
poverty
need help wherever they are
i want to finish by saying thank you
thank you to my wife sadia and
my family for your endless
support it's been a tough five years
and i know how lucky i am to
have you thank you to
the returning officer mary harpley
your team and those across london
for delivering this election under
incredibly
difficult circumstances thank you to
the other candidates in these elections
who put forward a positive vision
for our city and congratulations to
those who've been elected
to the london assembly thank you to my
supporters
for all your hard work phoning londoners
delivering leaflets
and knocking on doors you have been
brilliant and most importantly thank you
to
my fellow londoners for the trust
you've placed in me once again today
it's a privilege to serve thank you